voilà le smartphone c'est le a6 de
hisense alors smartphone très très
atypique vous montrez de tout cas c'est
hallucinant parce qu'en fait vous avez
un double écran alors on a l'habitude en
ce moment d'avoir des écrans plus grands
des écrans qui se plient les écrans tous
les côtés ça c'est marrant parce que
vous avez effectivement patrick roy et
de côté vous avez vaucluse
c'est assez typique c'est un truc a
jamais été vue ni c'est assez
intéressant
[Musique]
autour du mwc
c'était juste top j'ai rencontré plein
de monde et justement je vous près d'une
boîte que j'ai rencontrés pour la
première fois série sense alors si on
remonte encore un peu avant au mois de
janvier et j'étais au cs à las vegas
j'étais rencontrer le stand hisense
découvrir un de leurs produits et dans
la vidéo j'avais passé un message
maintien
dans le monde avec sense quelques
contacts puisse rester connectés et on
discutait pas à porter ses fruits et on
s'est rencontré au mwc
je vous ramène avec moi à barcelone et
on va découvrir un produit très atypique
c'est le a6 vous allez voir il est assez
surprenant
on y lit sur le sombre et 16 go mw
s'était créé ici c'est écrit en gros on
est avec damien des raisins très bien
merci
je n'étais pas très sympa merci de
m'accueillir les mercis données avec les
dealers hisense je sais pas si vous
connaissez
c'est une marche pour ce qu ils assez
méconnu encore aujourd'hui en france
donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir présenter l
16 dire qui vous êtes ce que vous faites
et je vous montre un produit qui est
très intéressante qui était assis ce
qu'il a sur la bloque et qu'il a voilà
comment pareil dans quelques heures
c'est qu'ils aient très bonne question
tu l'as dit sept sondés pas encore très
connu en france parce que la filiale la
marque est tout jeune
on a quatre ans d'existence une voiture
nationale a en france en force des
garnements en france 4 en france mais à
l'international existe depuis 1969
à l'époque on faisait des radios comme
beaucoup de choco
construit à l'époque et on s'est mis à
fabriquer des téléviseurs donc ensuite
du gros électroménager de la téléphonie
aujourd'hui on fait plein marque de
produit par don de la maison gros
électronique est rodé grand public ou
électroménager on a en france on est sur
trois catégories de point de vue donc le
téléviseur gros électroménager et
smartphones
sachant qu'on a une patte particulière
un adn particulier c'est de rendre le
premium abordable d'accord dans tous les
produits que qu'on va proposer sur le
marché français c'est toujours des
produits abordables tout une joute alors
sa licence en chine
c'est énorme vous êtes pour la quatrième
fois marché ouais alors à
l'international monde on est quatrième
fabricant mondial de télémédecine petite
anecdote on est leader sur marché
battait depuis 15 ans et laure noualhat
sur un marché d'un milliard 400 millions
d'habitants c'est pas mal ce que
commença voyant voilà ça qui est
intéressant c'est très lourd à
l'international une petite feature en
france comment est ce que vous vous
positionnez parcours ou marché du
smartphone aujourd'hui en france
on va proposer aujourd'hui des produits
la langue grosso modo de 200 à 500 euros
donc encore une fois l'idée c'est que
sur que ce soit de 200 à 500 euros on
puisse proposer les dernières
technologies reconnaissance faciale
digital les écrans note chouater
et c'est alors toutes les dernières
technologies d'affichage existe entre
genève et dans l'ue qu'un petit piqué à
six exactement le 1 6 qui est un produit
comme tu l'as dire particulier c'est un
écran full hd super amoled d'un côté
d'un calcul jusque-là basique et la
particularité c'est que je le retourne
les verrières j'ai un écran et iq donc
un écran de liseuses
[Musique]
en termes de spec vous avez un écran
super amoled avec une diagonale de 6
pouces c'est du f hd + et au dos vous
avez un écran e-ink de 5,6 pouces en
termes de performance est un qualcomm
snapdragon 660 alors comme les deux
écrans faux-pas ce faux pas se tromper
la caméra qui est ici c'est bien la
caméra selphy c'est une caméra de 16
mégapixels et de votre côté vous avez en
caméra principale une caméra de 12
mégapixels vous avez si giga de ram à
l'intérieur soit 64 giga de stockage
soit 128 go de stockage que vous pouvez
monter grâce à une carte micro sd à 250
giga om vaut de l'autonomie c'est une
batterie de 3300 milliards erreur et
vous avez alors si vous regardez en
termes de design sur le côté vous avez
le capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée
sur le bouton ça c'est plutôt cool
bouton volume on à de l'usb type ses
haut parleurs ici et ça c'est le bouton
vous dans nos têtes à quoi ça sert un
compte c'est pour activer le linky vous
appuyez sur votre bouton ça vaut couper
30 devant vous retourner et là vous
arrivez sur votre écran e-ink alors ça
c'est la première possibilité pour
pouvoir activer la deuxième solution
vous prenez vous montez continue inc
vous arrive et hop vous tournez votre
smartphone et là vous arrivez sur la
partie alors la partie n'est qu'elle est
intéressant parce que vous l'utilisez
effectivement comme une liseuse
d'ailleurs c'est le but d'une liseuse
mais pour un aussi très intéressant
lorsque vous n'avez plus de batterie sur
votre smartphone et bien vous pouvez
carrément venir l'utiliser sa pompera
beaucoup moins de batterie ça c'est
intéressant ça pourra vous sauver la vie
à paquet fois là haut up on peut
utiliser aussi la caméra riez en caméra
de cette fille alors forcément l'écran
est pas hyper hyper optimisé mais ça
marche j'ai l'impression de vrac un un
effet un peu carbone c'est sympa tu me
disait par exemple sur le marché du
smart
vous avez du premium en chine oui mais
pour un transfert marcheront c'est sympa
des produits vous allez m c'est une
bonne question là je vais prendre un peu
de recul par rapport aux produits
notre enjeu nous chez snc de se faire
connaître d'accord très clairement on
est une grande société en france on est
jeune donc il faut se faire connaître
on va exposer sort de l'euro 2000
vainqueur de foot donc on espère que la
france veut aller
et loin mais voilà on s'est vraiment
l'enjeu et c'est en démontrant bas à ton
public aux français que l'on sait faire
des bons produits qu'on pourra continuer
à proposer des produits va toujours
toujours d'ailleurs qualité saint-marcel
c'est vraiment l'enjeu pour nous
maintenant on est sur un smartphone qui
coûte 499 euros ça qui va coûter 499
euros parce que pour l'instant il n'est
absolument pas disponible il arrivera
second semestre 2010 9 alors on en
reparlera
je trouve ça intéressant comme concept
parce que c'est pas un produit qui va se
vendre à des millions et des millions et
des millions fin tant mieux pour elle si
c'est le cas mais je pense pas c'est un
produit qui est vraiment nicher pour des
personnes qui par exemple vaut lire dans
les transports en commun et qui ne vont
pas forcément route ça y est tout le
temps avec deux device donc là vous avez
votre smartphone vous avez votre liseuse
de tout et ça c'est vraiment intéressant
que je sais pas vous ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que c'est votre cas est-ce que
vous par exemple vous prenez le bus
longtemps le métro le train est ce que
vous lisez dans les transports en commun
et au final est un smartphone comme
celui là avec une liseuse
vous trouvez que ça a un sens et est ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
je vous invite à marquer tout ça en bas
on commenté à l'ats beat it moi est-ce
que vous connaissiez hisense est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter par
alice sur un produit d'accès
je vous parle de celui là je voulais
présenter un aussi a pas très longtemps
parce que j'étais au cs avec as donc
dites moi ce que vous en pensez je vous
invite bien évidemment rester connecté
parce qu'on va reparler des scènes on va
tester des produits il y aura plein de
choses intéressantes à dire de suite
voilà soyez sat nous engage à bientôt
[Musique]